Part C find the time at which the speed
of the particle is three so let's just
remind ourselves what speed is it's the
magnitude of velocity so if you have the
X actually let me draw it this way if
you have the X dimension of or the X
component of a velocity right over there
so this is the rate of which X is
changing with respect to time and you
have the Y component of the velocity you
have the Y component of the velocity
let's say it looks something like that
that is dy DT then the then the speed is
going to be the magnitude of the sum of
those two vectors so this right over
here the magnitude of this of this
vector right over here is going to be
the speed well what's the magnitude of
that
well the Pythagorean theorem tells us
it's going to be the square root of your
X component of velocity squared so DX DT
the rate at which X is changing with
respect to time to time squared plus
your Y component dy DT squared this
right here is the speed and we need to
figure out what time is this thing equal
to three so let's figure that out so the
square root of what's the X component of
our velocity well they told us over here
the X component of our velocity is
cosine of T squared so cosine of T
squared we're going to square that whole
thing and then plus the Y component of
the velocity the rate the rate of change
it with the rate at which Y is changing
with respect to time that's e to the 0.5
T and we're going to square that so plus
e to the 0.5 T and we're going to square
that this right over here is our
expression for speed as a function of
time and we just have to figure out when
does this thing when does this thing
equal 9 so there's a couple of ways we
could just subtract 9 or sorry when does
this equal 3
when does the
equal three and so we could try to we
could just subtract three from both
sides and input this into our solver or
we could begin to simplify this a little
bit we could square both sides and you
would get cosine let me write it this
way you could get cosine of T squared
squared plus e to the 0.5 T and then
squaring that well two point times zero
point five is just one so this is the
same thing as e to the t is equal to
nine and now we can subtract 9 from both
sides and we get cosine of T squared
squared I could have writen cosine
squared of T squared but this makes it a
little bit clearer I think plus e to the
t minus 9 is equal to zero and now once
again in this part of the AP exam we can
use our calculators so let's use our
calculators to solve let's use it to
solve for in this case T but I'll do
everything in terms of X so the equation
0 is equal to is equal to let me just
delete all of this actually just to get
it out of the way all right it's equal
to cosine and I'm going to use X as my
variable cosine of x squared close that
parentheses and then I want to square
the cosine the whole thing plus e to the
T so second e to the but my variable
that I'm going to solve for is X I'm
just replacing all the T's with X just
for inputting into the calculator e to
the X minus 9 minus 9 is equal to zero
is equal to zero we already have this
set equal to zero and so we click enter
and then we could we could just use our
previous answer as our initial guess and
we click we have to do this little blue
solve there so I click alpha solve let
the calculator munch on it a little bit
and it gets T is equal to or X is equal
to but this is really T to point one
nine six so we get T
approximately two point one nine six did
I type that in right 2.19 yep and round
that up and we are all done